there are countless stories of mistakes
and spontaneous moments that happen on
movie shoots
sometimes these surprises give a scene a
feeling of authenticity or a dose of
inspiration
and if they're in the final cut they
definitely made the movie better here
are some of our favorite
unplanned essentials more than four
decades since hitting theaters the 1976
boxing drama rocky is a household name
that's grown into a massive billion
dollar franchise like its protagonist
though the film was a bit of an underdog
when it was released the budget for the
first installment was slim
relative to the surrounding industry at
just above 1 million dollars it recouped
those expenses 225 times over but the
low budget production of the first film
is still apparent in various places
sylvester stallone wrote the screenplay
in only three and a half days and the
film was shot in just four weeks
he thought that if nothing else the
movie would show that in his own words
an unknown quantity can produce a
diamond in the rough
no matter how the circumstances of
someone's life are stacked against them
the humble italian stallion and his
creator aren't the only unknown
quantities that made rocky a huge hit
because of the low budget there wasn't
always enough funding to get extras
additional cameramen or even permits so
when they shot the popular scene of
rocky running through the italian market
they did it gorilla style from the back
of a van
because of this setup the stahl owners
didn't even know there was a movie being
filmed
one of them just happened to toss
stallone in orange and he managed to
catch it
a wholesome unplanned moment that set
the tone and left us rooting for the
hero even harder
leonardo dicaprio has subjected himself
to all kinds of physical torment for the
sake of various roles most notably the
revenant in 2015
finally earning his long overdue oscar
the masterful performer really proved
his medal though when he powered through
an injury where no reasonable person
would have expected him to
as calvin candy in 2012's django
unchained dicaprio played a posh and
pampered plantation owner the total
opposite of the rugged trapper he
portrayed in the revenant but during an
outburst at the dinner table dicaprio's
character slammed his hand down and he
actually cut himself on a piece of glass
considering that the wound later
required medical attention no one would
have blamed the actor for breaking
character
rendering the scene unusable but
dicaprio kept acting this act
represented the perverse unhinged
character so well
that it was left in the final cut of the
movie making for an iconic scene in
which dicaprio not only stayed in
character but arguably elevated the
moment
one transgression that often begs
forgiveness on a movie set is
forgetfulness
the job of an actor includes a lot of
memorization and every so often someone
forgets their lines but occasionally
forgetting one's dialogue is the most
true to character thing an actor can do
of course this is only the case if
you're lucky enough to play a character
who's
well a bit of an airhead derek zoolander
in 2001's zoolander
is probably the poster child for this
kind of role in one famous scene ben
stiller forgets one of his lines so he
simply repeats something he said a
minute earlier at the beginning of the
scene he asks
so why male models zoolander is
wondering why male models are chosen to
become assassins david duchovny's
character offers him an extensive
explanation involving male models
advantageous physical condition and
their ability to penetrate exclusive
circles
not to mention their most important
quality they don't think for themselves
stiller forgot what his response was
supposed to be so he improvised the now
classic line
but why male models
you serious i just i just told you that
the image of an intimidating character
casually stroking a cat with unnerving
tenderness has become a bit of a trope
but it was completely unplanned when it
occurred in 1972's the godfather
not only was it unscripted it almost
ruined the scene in which marlon brando
as don vito corleone nonchalantly
discusses matters of life and death
while caressing the feline in his lap
the key word though is almost the feline
actually ended up lending some extra
life to the scene in a way that movie
buffs love
the cat had been running around the
studio earlier in the day and when it
ended up on marlon brando's lap during
the scene the animal lover just went
with it
even though the sound crew worried that
the cat's purring would ruin the dawn's
now iconic lines
fortunately the feline and the
oscar-winning actor were a perfect duo
and totally stole the show
in the lord of the rings the two towers
the second installment of peter
jackson's trilogy legolas gimli and
aragorn find the slaughtered band of
urukai who captured mary and pippin and
they assume that the young hobbits have
also been killed
in his grief aragorn takes out his anger
on a nearby helmet
more than rage and defeat though
aragorn's outburst is one of pain
what most audience members don't know is
that actor viggo mortensen actually
broke his toe on the take that made it
into the final movie
another mistake also inadvertently takes
the same movie to another level
as aon stares off into the distance the
wind rips a flag from its pull
a sad commentary on the state of rohan
though this was unplanned according to
behind the scenes commentary it augments
the brooding nature of the scene
and a quick thinking camera operator
tracked the movement to heighten its
impact even further
an upset stomach on the set of 1981's
indiana jones raiders of the lost ark
led to a script change that ended up
becoming one of the film's most
memorable moments
harrison ford revealed in a reddit ama
that the script called for him to fight
an expert swordsman but he was suffering
from
dysentery and found it tough to be out
of his trailer for more than a few
minutes without having to run back to it
reviewing the script had made it clear
that it could take days to finish
shooting the scene which did not sound
appetizing at all to ford in his
condition so how did ford get out of
three days of shooting
by bringing a gun to a knife fight
[Music]
[Applause]
the poor stuntman had practiced his
swordmanship for days only for his
character to be coolly dispatched by
indy without any of the hand-to-hand
sword-to-whip combat he had been
training for
a few movies throughout the decades
stand out as examples of the
quintessential and quotable new york
city
one of the most famous of these films is
midnight cowboy and one line in
particular has become a permanent part
of pop culture
as for the origins of that famous line
it was improvised out of necessity
because as star dustin hoffman tells it
a cab driver ran a red light and drove
right through the set
an occurrence that's itself quite a
characteristic new york event
however higher ups on the film have
questioned whether the moment truly was
organic or whether there was an extra in
the cab and the truth is that it was a
little of both
allegedly the team was inspired by the
initial truly unplanned scene and then
used an extra to recreate more takes
like it
we don't know if the mistake was the
original unscripted scene or if it was
one of the recreations but we do know
that regardless of which version is true
the mistake directly or indirectly
helped make the movie unforgettable
daniel craig emerging from the ocean and
casino royale it's an
iconic scene that was never meant to
happen it certainly wasn't the plan to
with one lingering shot
reinvent the classic bond character as a
beefcake for a new generation of
audiences but that's exactly what it did
a moment from the scene was featured in
the trailer and a still photo was used
as promotional material
fans even assumed the shot was a nod to
ursula andres emerging from the sea in
the original bond movie dr no from 1962
if only all mistakes turned out this
well so how does something this great
happen by accident
the original story craig gave was that
he was supposed to be swimming but the
water there was unexpectedly shallow due
to the presence of a sand shelf in the
area so he stood up and walked off in a
later interview he added that it was
because he thought that he looked stupid
quote pretending to be cool by swimming
instead he just stood up and walked off
so one of the most memorable shots of
craig's james bond ended up not only
being an accident but a result of him
throwing in the beach towel on a
particular acting choice
amelia rinaldi also known as mia
initially has a great deal of trouble
believing she's a princess
it just doesn't add up at school the
protagonist of 2001's the princess
diaries is clumsy
awkward and unpopular admiring it boys
from afar but never really talking to
anyone other than her best friend who is
also
on the relative fringes of high school
society even after she receives the
royal
treatment following the revelation of
her identity and her crush begins to
give her attention
their kiss is marred by the fact that
her foot gets stuck in a fishing net
no amount of makeovers or royal shoe
fittings can change the fact that mia
has two left feet so when she and her
friend lily are walking on the bleachers
in one scene and mia slips and takes a
dive audiences are no more likely to bet
an
eye than mia herself this just seems
like something that the often graceless
heiress would do
and hathaway however later said that she
slipped and fell completely by accident
but despite bursting out laughing she
kept on acting she never expected to see
that moment again much less that
millions of people around the world
would witness it however director gary
marshall decided to use the take of
hathaway slipping above
all the others he kept it he kept it
because it was a charming moment
a good soldier fights through peril and
injury and apparently so does a good
actor
you've probably heard of a number of
performers who do their own stunts but
george mckay never expected one
particular scene from the 2019 war film
1917 to put him on that list
while his character scofield's grueling
sprint at the end of the film was
undoubtedly an intense climax to his
mission the actor wasn't meant to take
any hits as he ran across the
battlefield he had come out of rehearsal
for the scene unscathed but there are no
guarantees of timing in such a complex
scene
on the actual day of shooting he found
himself taking multiple blows from a
slew of oncoming soldiers but an actor
keeps going until the director calls for
a cut and for such an important moment
in the film he knew he couldn't throw in
the towel himself
so he kept moving and director sam
mendes never halted the take
he must have realized that despite
deviating from rehearsal something even
more intense was happening mckay spoke
to jimmy fallon about the take
and again we'd rehearsed it for weeks
and would rehearse that you didn't get
knocked into and then on the day you
know
you take some hits but the rule is you
don't stop unless they say stop
the shot that was never meant to happen
ended up being one of the greatest
triumphs of mckay's performance
there are some moments that have widely
been regarded as accidents even by those
who directed them
only for the actors involved to later
allege the bungles were actually
intentional moments of improvisation
one such moment featuring gandalf from
the beginning of the fellowship of the
ring immediately comes to mind
[Music]
peter jackson's commentary on the dvd
states that this moment was an accident
that ian mcallen truly did bonk his head
and that his acting remained so superb
that jackson decided to use the take
anyway it works to humanize the great
wizard and it cements the genuineness of
the friendship between the mystical
being
and the hobbit on his website however
mckellen states that the clumsy move was
his idea
and jackson simply didn't know check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one